hi i'm john early and i'm caper land and
in celebration of our new peacock
special would it kill you to laugh are
you proud
yeah yeah this is above five ounces i
gotta chug this
john kate that's what i'm talking about
where we play out of touch celebrities
who have a very big public falling out
what sparked the lawsuit well after all
these years i still don't know but gun
to my head i would say i did it for
sport it's so strange because you look
12 but you also look 60.
we are going to prove that we're real
life best friends and so we're going to
play a game of who's more likely to
who's more likely to answer when you
call out of the blue
okay me yeah thank you for the honesty
there i have a fear of my phone that's
very male i think
who's more likely to have a terrible
food opinion it's like mediterranean
food technically i say we're both pretty
i think we're both capable of scathing
critique of food but we're also real
food lovers i would say maybe mean
[Music]
wow i just because i mean we're both
particularly romantic about restaurants
but i would say sometimes when a
restaurant isn't failing to meet our
romantic expectations okay
i acknowledge yeah yeah because it's
harder to ignore harder emotionally yeah
i'll wait yourself our waitress
something's off she's frozen who's more
likely to know what's trending in pop
culture
you
okay yeah
great here to dance who's more likely to
be cancelled
i actually don't know
i feel like we're equal i feel like
we're equal
we are at a standstill who's more likely
to be cool in front of their favorite
celebrity
i we're equal again but what does cool
probably
you
what do you mean though what is cool
like actually pulling it off for like
yeah i guess like being casual yeah
being like hey
i don't think we're either either okay
no no no no we're not so is there a
toast smell you know someone that's
what oh my god
there's more likely to give unsolicited
advice me okay
just saying we're all pink in the middle
oh my god i'm going home who's more
likely to run a fan account for a
boyfriend i guess john yeah cause you
you've run a fan account for boyfriend
no yeah exactly i ran out found a fan
account for tony when i was in middle
school
very happily so who's more likely to
tell you about the same show they've
been watching for a fourth time both of
us both of us yeah very kind of
there's a religious fervor to our
recommendations that's true call me when
you figure it out we've learned a lot
here today i loved it period and now
it's time for you to go stream would it
kill you to laugh which is only on
peacock i'm loving it
and if you don't you better go outside
and pick your switch
what does that mean it's a southern
expression for getting like a twig to be
spanked with
that's terrible
[Music]
you